comme chaque semaine depuis maintenant
deux mois Faustine 18 ans s'en va
rencontrer Bizan 12 ans pour faire du
tutorat commissaire comment ça va ça a
été ta journée à l'école
originaire du série bizarre est au
Québec depuis 4 ans
je m'appelle bilan c'est tout Faustine
est surtout bizarre à développer son
vocabulaire tendu à quel chapitre alors
cette semaine est-ce que tu as bien
avancé ce jumelage a été rendu possible
grâce à l'initiative à deux pas de la
réussite un programme de tutorat lancé
en 2017 dans la naudière ou des
étudiants de cégep viennent en aide à
des élèves du primaire qui ont des défis
académiques à relever je me souviens
pourquoi pas c'est vraiment intéressant
avec des enfants et des enfants aussi et
dans mon projet plus personnel j'aime
être orthophoniste avec les enfants donc
c'était encore plus intéressant pour moi
ça m'a permis aussi vraiment de d'être
sûr de dans quel loi je vais aller la
particularité du modèle les étudiants
tuteurs ne sont pas rémunérés mais un de
leurs cours est crédité moi je trouve ça
c'est du bénévolat donc c'est aider les
autres c'est hyper intéressant il y a
pas très longtemps j'avais l'âge de
Bissen donc j'ai mis des fois peut-être
ce soit une adolescente ou une jeune
adulte qui puisse l'expliquer des fois
dans des termes dans des mots puis moi
j'avais jamais vu connu ça en France on
n'a jamais connu ça et au Québec ou
c'est une très belle initiative ce qu'il
choisisse de prendre de faire ce
projet-là c'est que ils ont des gens un
intérêt donc la première chose que ça
fait pour eux c'est que ça va venir
confirmer ou infirmer au niveau de
l'orientation professionnelle il y a des
étudiants qui sont intéressés par
l'orthophonie par l'enseignement par
toutes sortes de toutes formes de
relation d'aide on continue la lecture
on peut finir cette page là en slot
après on se fait un peu de vocabulaire
ça te va bizarre et son enseignante
voient déjà des améliorations grâce à
l'aide de Faustine facile
si je veux écrire une phrase
je pourrais chercher dans mes dans mes
exercices qu'on a fait avec elle pour
trouver une bonne belle phrase pour
l'ajouter dans mon texte puis ça va être
chaud ça vient vraiment s'ajouter à mon
enseignement là vraiment c'est vraiment
complémentaire à tout ce que je fais une
expérience qu'elle qualifie en ces mots
bénéfique est vraiment aidante oui
vraiment
jusqu'à présent le volet tutorat a deux
pas de la réussite c'est 250 tuteurs
pour autant d'élèves tutoré dans un
cégep et 4 écoles primaires
participantes dans l'anaudière
mais le co-fondateur du projet voit plus
grand ça demande que le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur prennent sous
son aile son programme de tutorat pour
le rendre accessible à tous les cégeps
du Québec c'est le ministère c'est leur
futur relève en fait qui vont aller dans
leurs écoles ou dans leur collège
université c'est une formule d'abord qui
est très économique ça coûte pas cher
pour le réseau et c'est une formule là
en bon québécoise d'efficacité de réseau
une rencontre à ce sujet est d'ailleurs
prévue avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur dans les
prochaines semaines ici Fanny Bussière
mais Nicole Radio-Canada l'Assomption